all right today is one week away from
Halloween and Isaac Isaac are you there
he is
who are you star-lord from what movie
great is it okay nice and what's going
on today it's not Halloween but it is
the family day for school free food free
rushman and free refreshments the Isaac
school is throwing a Halloween party for
the families of for the kids and their
families at the school so we're gonna go
and crash the party and style look at
this guy
oh oh I combed my hair put water take a
look like Star Wars in honors yeah I
combed it this week cuz to my friend
Scott and my teacher Kurt could
recognize me you mean your best
star-lord impersonation you don't know
in personation means like what is
star-lord today in the movie like give
me your best star-lord acting those
waiting for you too is in the background
oh good I'm waiting so we're gonna we're
gonna go ahead and head out TIPA still
at work she's gonna catch up with us and
a little bit and we shall go party at
hearty party hardy at school hi hi hi hi
I like it
movie are you watching in preparation
for the party
yeah we're watching guardians of the
galaxy
I think we're so excited about his
costume that he had thrown guardians of
the galaxy in order to get into
character get into his party zone are
you ready all right I see school now you
ready for this Isaac this was okay
we're song you sing
Oh
like waxes music
on me you know what that means you don't
know what it means it means you're gonna
buy me lunch this lunch is on me or this
toys on me or this whatever it is on me
one two three four five seven eight and
you're strong how strong do you feel
right now I feel like I could punch you
and then you can go all the way through
that apartments yeah you're gonna be
stronger than me one day you know that
right get older you're gonna be nice and
strong and I'm gonna get old and like an
old man oh my don't be weak you make you
funny yourself it's sad I'm making fun
of myself and I can't let you like see
man I'm not old man then I'm gonna die
before that day okay there's a lot of
people because everyone's in line do you
know what they're in line for their food
food vouchers now so we got our pizza
and I just have a hard time opening his
soda we got it come on you're wearing
that costume star-lord
you forget your mask all your mess right
there that's like always the number one
thing that I lose when I go to parties
Halloween parties always leave my mat or
your friends at see one at the
refinishing and I go play with them okay
dokay save that pizza for mommy
go get mommy over there I mean mommy hey
mommy she'd read about the guys
we missed you
are you kissing the camera I got your
pizza
this one's for you macros can you do I
just look pretty good though the pizza
oh yeah I know
Isaacson when it's been on macros and
working out that guy
no I saw mine
what's happening
many
the kids
what
later I'm sure
where your mess I think where your mask
there he goes
like flings his glove off
hello friends we found Isaac this was
funny at school to have kids fling the
band
we found him watching the band where we
were looking for him
you wanna play music like them no
why you're gonna kill me convinced
energy comer would you eat hmm once you
hit the reset or I mean the playground
that's where all the energy comes out
that's true you know going crazy now
okay that's not even the playground the
playgrounds over there
whoa happy Halloween now it's one week
later after Isaac's Halloween party at
his school and today is the day of
Halloween and we're actually on our way
out we're gonna go to Joe's house are
you excited baby yeah we're gonna go
trick-or-treating you jealous house with
the doggies and Casey right now is
working oh so he'll be meeting us later
very soon
yeah so we're gonna the deal is that we
get to keep Isaac before sunset and now
it's 3:30 so we're gonna go trick or
treat and enjoy the time we have with
Isaac because later on tonight it's
gonna go to dead at health all right
let's go okay I'm gonna pick a tree
to treat no to the treat you practically
maybe yeah what are you gonna say
remember last year what did you say last
year when you were trick-or-treating our
tourniquet rate
oh yeah cuz you're a pirate huh that was
so cute all right we just got to Joe's
have you guys ready for Halloween
trick-or-treating yeah you got a little
bunch of new toys yeah check this out I
just got on electronic yodeling pickle
yodeling pickle yeah so check this out
yo Lee what are you playing with baby so
you go like this watch it cool you guys
are cool drum I just learned how to play
this I've been practicing this today
what do you do that sing into it play a
song together what are you nuts cool you
should make a band the cool bros band
rose bad try this one you just blow into
it and then you play the keys you better
record really come in EU pools we want
two three four five six I don't think
you guys will ever need to have your own
kids you already have one
he's so cute they're working you like
the mom like every day look at my brandy
boy wait is he
Stegosaurus look at this cutie is he
stuck Kenny wall
come here Brown American you off brownie
come here brother
brownie brownie boy brown brown humpy to
come we'll hook in that brownie oh yeah
I think I think it's stuck yeah that is
Henley oh there we go oh there you go
come here buddy Oh cute I'm a whole
bunch of costumes raptured and the
feedbag asaurus now he's worried a
little Raptor I'm trying to see which
outfit was the best for him I think this
one sorry
no one's cute and he matches Isaac to no
darlin
and he matches your shorts and my pants
no we're all wearing red or burgundy
brownie brownie Brown for me
yes I'm head out now yeah pop you let go
get your candy boy so we're at the
pumpkin patch
we are just pretty much waiting for Sun
to set now could we realize that not a
lot of people are trick-or-treating
there's three the seminary
do you remember when you wore this hat
and this bandana for your third birthday
no I'm wearing it I got a bunny yeah
this is his old woody costume on he
turned three you still have it you have
to put your head there
fili ET I think no no no gonna fit it
through you're gonna get the hook okay
go on
hey kppa stuck on the other side I know
I'm stuck on this side where all the
jumpers are and kids
we're like the high school grads are
like the older kids are like visiting
during recess yeah I'm that cool kid
that has high school friends Brown is
why me he's like you're their matching
you're wearing brown and burgundy hey my
brownie boy I think you wants to run up
and down there with the kids you ready
to go come on we're gonna go
trick-or-treating
yeah oh now you want to go okay go for
change I'm getting mad what you don't
talk to me like that okay just for that
we're not going to go trick-or-treating
anymore come on put your shoes on little
punk funny I'm 50 alright so now we're
starting the trick-or-treat hmm
everybody's here and brought flashlights
so you guys can see while I'm logging
and we had to wait til it was sunset
because everyone around this
neighborhood well decides to wait till
the sunset ooh look up pretty that look
come on focus
this camera socks up focusing look at
that that's horrible
look how green it is there we go hold on
there's a beautiful sunset you're ready
boy Kelly honey oh cool no we got Maddy
Sophie and brownie Joe Jess Casey yeah
this sexy nurse outfit
forget her hahaha and Annabelle girl
come on put your mask on you ready
what are you gonna say trick a trick
trick-or-treat ring the doorbell right
there good job they have to stay took a
treat besides your SAT two times once
before they open the door so that you
can know that your trick-or-treat and
then again once they open it because
then that's when they give you the candy
down
Rula scary let's go in there yeah how do
you do that
cabinet Brown where are we going now
Isaac's going to that haunted house and
we're going to a haunted house I'm not
scared
no have you ever been to a haunted house
before No
this dude is my worst nightmare that's
your worst nightmare yeah that's my
childhood a monster scary guy or so
damaged he was a serious good one you
want Isaac back alright we got another
kid in the group so Isaac what's your
worst nightmare
mommy's Chucky with yours oh that
bicycle dude
oh oh uh oh I saw good hi wimzie
pseudo pick Sudha as it looks like I
think a lot of sugar chairs come here
because it's absent map today this is a
really rich way placing people might be
very rich here so they could buy like
decorations so what would you do so
someone he said trick-or-treating so and
said here's an Xbox for you oh you'd be
so happy oh I'd be so happy get your
treat
only he changes his voice next level
trick-or-treating over here they got the
vehicles on standby what happened to the
walk down the street it's no your
neighborhood right
Oh cute
you wish that you had a you had a group
of friends to go trick-or-treating
oh yeah well maybe when you get older
sudhi I'll let you go trick-or-treating
by yourself
the drop-off is happening no one's home
news ain't no go the guy dropped off and
then tried just left that's funny yeah
that's the teenage way of treating these
days they just get get the friend get
that friend has a car yeah we're their
friend that has the car halfway through
buddy got keep going
house trick-or-treating today today I
think it's a successful night so far
yeah well how was last year's compared
to this today last year was a fail
because we ended up training really late
and we thought we started it we had a
good time cause I think we started like
her on either mine which is it can be
pretty late for some people and it turns
out that in our neighborhood it was
really late cuz nobody was timing out
candy anymore so last year was kind of a
fail but this year we started early
because we learned our lesson and it's
funny because we tried trying earlier
than usual like when the Sun was still
out and there was nobody out so we're
like man we just can't time it right but
it's easier to wait for churches to come
out then last year when we already
missed it this year it's been good so
far all right we're leaving the pack now
all the people are behind us now and
we're winning the race if all the we
want to race would be winning we're not
winning the race we're not winning the
race no more people are like getting
dropped off oh man we have more
competition coming up they keep cheating
they're cheating in the line
driving up to you got me
now we're back alright so we just
finished sugar Trini and look at all
this candy
don't worry you gonna flip it over and
then open a dope opportunity help you
ready yeah I'm going to swim on a swim
on a real quick oh actually we get
double the candy all right so that's
kite for faster buddy five six
I like your a straight line though are
you trying to get et to come home you
know I remember my dad recording me
doing the same thing and his camera was
like on your shoulder and yet the
eyepiece and I was always humongous like
and now a degeneration later I'm like
holding this tiny little box you want to
open like like I know he is like you can
count by twos Isaac
mara my there's more you gotta go
outside and knock on the door Charlie
get out of here
howdy y'all
we just dropped off Isaac at his dad's
house and he's having a Halloween
barbecue at his dad's house while we are
at JK office and I just got suited up
for a Halloween getup we are headed to
barbell barbell they have like a little
Halloween party going on and we're gonna
go see everyone else is up to you don't
look like Geo today howdy this is
growing shaggy though shaggy shaggy oh
yeah you got this though you got this
which is pretty shaggy you should have
missed QB do or or Velma or Daphne I
should thank you Lara Croft nice oh [ __ ]
oh where do you supposed to be I am a
metro lumberjack hurry with the pot Jeff
Kurr with the five guys I want to touch
my scent boxers and everything so you
would do a legit why would you do that
I want me to get you and you'd be easy
you're gonna need to target how did you
get it today